he is at wait time ending winner and
inductee into the broadcasters wing at
the Baseball Hall of Fame who calls
games for the MLB Network and host
studio 42 with Bob Costas Bob Costas
ladies
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you so great by the way
to hear you do play-by-play of a
baseball game there is no pleasure I
love more than that yeah yeah nobody
doesn't like it did you do tonight is
hey hey listen to it you because it's
like I don't know Jack Paar announcing a
game it's witty
it's elegant there's jokes that your
broadcast partner doesn't get yeah
decided that if you and my friends and
people kind of in my yeah orbit yeah if
they get it and they laugh I appreciate
it that's good enough they said a lot of
downtime in a game it calls for it yeah
so you are in the Baseball Hall of Fame
so great I got to ask you though the you
feel bad that Pete Rose is not in but
you are it seems wrong Bob you know they
messed that up at the beginning he
should have been banned from baseball
but he should have been on the ballot
for the Hall of Fame that's simple
enough but subsequently while that
debate went on he did so so many things
that made it difficult to support him
yeah so many things just were unseemly
yeah yeah when you when you fight when
you find out that he was dallying with
an underage defense so let's not deal
with all the baby nonetheless exactly so
but look at whatever I have you want I
was like I'm good because especially a
week like this I was so depressed
because of the Muller thing and if I
could get Bob don't you just talk about
sports except you know what sports it's
always Costa poet as soon as it leaves
politics you know Jackie Robinson
Muhammad Ali Robert Kraft making the
happy ending an issue as it finally
should be in America and Robert Kraft
being in the same sentence with Jackie
Robinson is rather disturbing actually
well no one defends Robert Kraft and I
feel like I should I know why kasauli
has to take up the lost causes I don't
like his politics but you know he's a he
lost his wife of like many decades mhm
so he's getting a little love at the
place and you know with them anyway you
see anybody like today who's in that
league with with Ollie and Arthur rash
and you know people who really changed
culture Curt Flood and labret LeBron
James has tried to step up you know
Malcolm Jenkins with the Philadelphia
Eagles Doug Baldwin they've been they've
been articulate and well informed Colin
Kapernick certainly yep Colin Kaepernick
that one got a blood Colin Kaepernick
called
attention to a very important issue and
paid for it he and paid for like golly
he did it with grace the reason I
wouldn't elevate him to the level of an
ally or an Arthur Ashe or Kareem who
continues to be a public intellectual or
Curt Flood whom you mentioned is that
every time he speaks which is rarely he
says something that doesn't necessarily
yeah you know when he says yeah I I
don't vote because the oppressor will
ever never allow you to vote your way
out of your oppression I guess it
doesn't matter to him that when he first
took a knee Obama was president right
and when he was blackballed from the
league Trampas president he was not
helpful in the election because he said
I remember like tearing him a new
[ __ ] about it he was like oh Hillary
she's a racist he Trump's a racist what
is it yeah yeah that's okay so we'll
talk to him yeah I mean he did his yard
he did
but right he didn't think others can
carry it forward right more effectively
so football now you've talked about I
mean you were one of the first brave
ones to talk about the fact that okay
this is this is really organized brain
damage that's going on here and we love
the game and look I'm a libertarian on
stuff like yeah these players know the
cost so if they find joint and are
willing to sacrifice we all do stupid
things when we're young I'm sure I'm
paying for some of them now but you know
the answer of course always is well this
was allowed to have biggest football is
just the ultimate cash cow right yeah
why is that why of the sport why do we
love football so much more than the
other sports
well we're violent we're a violent
people you think it's once a week
alright so every game feels like what
sig deal it's Sunday yeah Sunday your
teeth yours yeah your team whatever team
plays once a week your team plays once a
week but we want them all yeah it's
ideal for gambling then you have your
fantasy teams and it becomes an
obsession look when the NFL Draft
becomes a big deal like it's some sort
of quasi national holiday when more
people watch the NFL Draft
then watch really exciting NBA playoff
games on the same night or NHL Stanley
Cup playoff games
something's warped but since there is
something about the violence I felt like
if if you are a a fleet or a coach and
you were interviewed I noticed there is
one word that comes up every time over
and over again if I it is well pretend
you're an athlete yeah if I if I ask you
like what can you do to get back in the
game what do you have to do what haven't
you been doing taking them one at a time
aggressive or aggressive that's at every
single that's all they talk we got to be
more aggressive aggressive aggressive
aggressive is just this fist it's a new
head coach at the University of Colorado
made a big deal about the way I grew up
with the game it's all about hitting
it's all about aggression blah blah blah
and two of the trustees said they could
not vote in favor of his hiring they
could not even though they knew they'd
be out voted
they weren't down with that they
couldn't any longer justify the amount
of money being poured into football when
this is supposed to be an academic
institution and maybe the values of
football they're no longer aligned with
what should be the values of an academic
institution
you